buenos días hoy tenemos el placer de
poder hablar aquí el único like
constante alexander
cinco veces
y bueno nos va a explicar y nos va a
detallar un poco cómo es la situación en
esta ciudad que últimamente ha sido
bombardeada
en los últimos días hemos visto la
situación ha empeorado
especialmente desde que las tropas
ucranianas están intentando retomar el
control
y ha habido bombardeos no solamente a
objetivos militares principales
civiles cómo es la situación en estos
momentos en la ciudad mikolajki
y
desde el primer día de la guerra los
rusos han bombardeado mykolaiv casi
todos los días a veces tenemos un
descanso de uno o dos días hoy es el
segundo día que no nos bombardean bueno
bombardearon una zona de la región de
mykolaiv afortunadamente no hay víctimas
civiles durante el último bombardeo a
principios de semana fuimos bombardeados
tres veces en un día por la noche a las
7 de la mañana y a las 4 de la tarde
durante estos bombardeos murieron 10
personas y unas 60 resultaron heridas
de ese hotel
vilas este desde luego para nada
el ejército ruso se está retirando de
kiev y otras ciudades como butch a josh
homme el vemos un aumento del ejército
ruso en el obras de gerson vienen de
crimea hay un aumento en parte de la
región de mykolaiv y hay suposiciones de
que los rusos van a atacar mykolaiv
pronto estamos preparados los bombardeos
continúan solo porque quieren asustar a
los civiles para que nos rindamos o
entremos en pánico y no sepamos qué
hacer
kuwait visto en wii si muchas
a nuestros civiles que tienen la
oportunidad de salir de la ciudad es
mejor que lo hagan para estar seguros y
no ser víctimas de los bombardeos los
bombardeos son caóticos apuntan a todas
las direcciones de la ciudad a todos los
distritos no importa si es un objetivo
militar o humanitario jardines
infantiles escuelas hospitales
el texto estará en la prevista por
siempre
197 disco diviértete
aumentaron invierte doctorados aquí es
cuál
de carne está vendiendo ayuda
humanitaria aquí a mi colegio me
gustaría saber si hay suficiente comida
medicamentos en la ciudad
en s
la situación se mantiene estable por hoy
después de la retirada del ejército ruso
hemos abierto las carreteras sanz y pro
propio de esquí y aldesa así que tenemos
toda la comida la medicina que
necesitamos y todo lo que se necesita
para vivir en la ciudad tenemos
problemas con la gasolina uno de los
principales objetivos de los ataques
rusos son las terminales petrolíferas
dicen que sólo atacan las terminales
petrolíferas militares pero también
destruyen la infraestructura civil
entonces hoy tenemos un problema con la
gasolina y se ven las filas en las
gasolineras pero la situación está bajo
control y la situación humanitaria en la
ciudad tenemos electricidad agua toda la
infraestructura de la ciudad funciona
correctamente
por cierto el transporte público
funciona
sin a perón que me está próximo y normal
nadie
las públicas de transporte como es la
red
creo que está la gente unida que va a
ser capaz de la ciudad o por el
contrario están abiertos
muchas personas que han preferido
marcharse porque tienen miedo a buscar
lugares más seguros
es acaso si es persona viene en mixtos o
portugal ese tipo
del organismo nace restauran el pecho de
tobatí la ciudad está unida desde el
primer día de la guerra y empezó a
trabajar como un solo organismo nuestros
restaurantes empezaron a cocinar la
comida para los militares nuestros
constructores construyen fortificaciones
y puestos de control y nuestras empresas
de servicios públicos hacen su trabajo
más aún traen las máquinas militares
rusas destruidas y las máquinas que
abandonaron para dárselas a nuestros
soldados en el frente
si
escogí a otros que vivir su vida si era
así a los de pecho le permite su amistad
podremos del g7 podremos deje ya te
tengo que decir que al principio todo el
mundo tenía miedo de la guerra pero
cuando el miedo desaparece la gente
entiende que hay que proteger la ciudad
hay que proteger el país y todo el mundo
ocupa hoy su lugar los militares en sus
lugares el ejército la guardia nacional
la defensa territorial y la parte
humanitaria lo que significa proveedores
dos medicinas y todo lo que el ejército
necesita madera arena todos están
haciendo su trabajo toda la ciudad está
muy motivada porque todos entendemos por
qué estamos de pie estamos de pie por
nuestra tierra nuestras mujeres niños
por todo lo que tenemos ellos son
ocupantes y no tienen motivación la
única motivación que tienen es luchar
por putin así que dejan sus tanques
máquinas y simplemente huyen cuando se
enfrentan al primer ataque
tan bueno y técnico y virrey perverso de
distancia
mykolaiv al igual que odessa es una
importante ciudad portuaria y las
fuerzas navales rusas están llevando un
bloqueo
cómo afecta esto
tanto ahora como en el futuro las minas
que están habiendo en el mar qué va a
pasar después cuando termine la guerra y
oportunidades y posibilidades de que se
pueda terminar el mar es un himno a la
coacción de esa estrategia está mal de
todo y sobre sin duda nikoláy bio de
esas son ciudades estratégicas para
cortar a ucrania del mar rusia intentará
ocupar mykolaiv y odessa por supuesto no
sólo son ciudades estratégicas por su
acceso al mar sino también importantes
puertos marítimos de exportaciones de
mora de tacos
podemos decir que mykolaiv y los puertos
marítimos de la gran o desaprueben el
90% de los cargueros de exportación de
ucrania
eso significa que toda la producción
agrícola que exportamos a otros países
pasa por nuestros puertos marítimos así
que es táctico estratégico e importante
para los lugares de exportación no
tenemos ninguna exportación para el día
de hoy porque es realmente peligroso
ahora
rus ya mí no nuestro mar negro y dicen
que lo hicimos nosotros y las minas se
desprendieron de las anclas es peligroso
así que no exportamos nada por ahora
claro que encontramos nuevas formas de
exportar a través de la frontera europea
pero la situación económica de mykolaiv
y ucrania es una gran pérdida para
nosotros y sentiremos esa pérdida en el
futuro porque todo este dinero que
obtendríamos por la exportación tuvimos
que invertirlo en la agroindustria
y
se ha convertido en un centro donde
están llevando un gran flujo de
y desplazados de otras zonas que están
siendo atacadas y desde aquí pues con
autobuses
este
más segura son directamente a otros
países de la región como moldavia
o polonia esto está afectando a lo que
son el transporte público de aquí
incluso al tema de los hoteles de las
fracturas
si hay un flujo mucho mayor porque
siguen acercándose las tropas rusas y lo
que es toda esta región no empieza la
gente terminó de marcharse como puede
mykolaiv
un poco poder llevar todo el problema de
las raíces del flujo de refugiados
896 peatones de autobuses añadir
transportaban luz de misia desde el
quinto día de la guerra los buses que
debían transportar a los habitantes de
mykolaiv alrededor de la ciudad se
utilizaron para la evacuación de
personas hicimos un formulario
electrónico
la gente puede rellenarlo y recibe una
llamada telefónica por la tarde y están
preparados para salir por la mañana en
bus hacia dos direcciones hacia odessa y
hacia la frontera con moldavia palanca
si van a odessa pueden utilizar el tren
para llegar al oeste de ucrania también
quien quiera puede cruzar la frontera
porque no te
nuestros buses también recogen a los
civiles en los pueblos que hemos
retomado los traemos a la ciudad y los
reubicamos en nuestros apartamentos
sociales algunos quieren marcharse así
que se van a odessa o palanca y unos 400
se están quedando en la ciudad por ahora
esta escena se dividirá dale al samur
fruta mambo de salvo palanca a tacos los
alimentamos pueden vivir aquí y volver a
sus pueblos después o ir más lejos
tenemos suficientes recursos y buses
para prestar este servicio no creo que
la guerra vaya a terminar pronto así que
tenemos este mecanismo y estamos
preparados para acoger los refugiados y
transportarlos al occidente y
eres
ya no determinadas cosas que se tomó el
próxima genís método pre mate en
vigencia del server mixta amor por el
arte y dale más la gente
rusia no solamente está bombardeando
objetivos militares ha estado
bombardeando
civiles hay gente que ha perdido sus
hogares otras casas que están dañadas al
igual que los hospitales algunos
hospitales que han sido afectados
qué puede hacer
de nikolai para poder ayudar a estas
personas que han perdido sus hogares o
incluso en el tema de los hospitales
como los médicos no pueden ahora
ayudar a los nuevos heridos cuando las
infraestructuras no están están siendo
bombardeadas
water bombs
de base desde el primer día nos
bombardean principalmente con bombas de
racimo el propósito de estas bombas es
atacar a personas vivas así que su
propósito es matar personas que estas
bombas no pueden dañar vehículos
blindados por supuesto todas las
víctimas son civiles caminaban por la
calle estaban cerca de una tienda los
bombardeos ocurren en todos los
distritos de la ciudad en los distritos
civiles hospitales jardines infantiles y
escuelas
inclusión se presta tienes posibles de
la coordinación de dati mixto la gracia
creo que es una de las formas de hacer
que los civiles tengan miedo de tomar la
ciudad
claro hay edificios dañados parcialmente
después del bombardeo unos 400 por ahora
pero hay edificios completamente
destruidos que no pueden ser
reconstruidos alrededor de 60 la gente
que vivía ya ha sido reubicada o
evacuada de la ciudad y los hospitales
ventanas destruidas muebles dañados
equipos lo arreglamos no tenemos
suficiente vidrio para arreglar las
ventanas así que usamos membranas para
empezar a arreglar las
fichas
todos tienen miedo después de los
bombardeos pero tengo que agradecer a
nuestros médicos que nos ayudan y hacen
su trabajo en condiciones tan difíciles
y la gente que sale de mykolaiv y recibe
ayuda en el extranjero me gustaría
agradecer a todos los países que nos
ayudan estoy seguro de que cuando
ganemos nuestra gente
y
de europa y mamá de mi objetivo
es increíble me
pongo una democracia si dichas
permanezco de páramo somos un equipo
verde diciendo todo
muchas gracias so lexander por tu tiempo
en nuestros momentos tan complicados
la ciudad de nicolai y bueno y
puedan venir tiempos mejores no
solamente esta ciudad es también para
toda otra nación muchas gracias al
equipo de france 24